hi my name is james miller on the prowl
olivarium contestant for the 2010 after
new graphic beep I live in Tuscaloosa
Alabama if you were to visit my town you
would fight a lot of great things to do
the University of Alabama a sub for some
great museums between the paul w brian
museum the restaurant warner our gal we
offer great opportunities we also may
want to try out sort of recreational
activities available in town we have a
lot of great biking hiking fishing and
and rivers streams right now i'm your
late-night nicollet in the north of town
I think what being green means to me and
friends my age is conserving and Natural
Resources recycling and recognizing a
great and global warming the shirt that
I have on now is from our school
celebrates her birthday that occurred
earlier today if our strength basis of
any famous explorer world theater are
probably choose in inventa he was a
Muslim explorers who saw Bob China
Russia and the Middle East as he
conducted extensive travels for this
reason I would love to trade places with
if someone gave me a free ticket to
anywhere in the world right now are
probably choose to go to the United
Kingdom it's the history culture
tradition and traditions there are
really fascinating I don't really know
how to fish all the information that I
gather in my brain I think a part of it
is my memory and another part of it is
that I've been looking at atlases and
other sources of information from the
time before I knew there was even a
geographic p so here's my advice to you
this look over information for a long
period of time and eventually you'll get
the hang of it a fireplace in charging
the Eric from a single day our Father
easily removed all dictatorial
governments first I think government
exists to serve they needed the people
not the other way around so that is why
I would do that first to sum it all up
here's a curious fact that I learned
what's world country is the world's
largest exporter of false teeth
you